Oh Canada it is a silly place hey shut
your mouth E firstly I want to clear
something up lots of people are confused
in regards to my nationality let me say
that I am a natural-born United States
citizen I do also have a Canadian
citizenship and was raised there for
most of my life
I'm a very proud American but you know I
did Canada too so please know that this
video is not aimed at all Canadians but
specifically the dumb ones who say
things like well America sucks there now
I know that anti Americanism exists
around the world but I personally have
had a lot of experience with it
firsthand in Canada the sad part is that
often the only explanation is something
like America thinks they're better than
everyone else they're plus their old fat
and stupid a really fat and stupid huh
okay well next time you get home use
some electricity to turn on your light
bulb then kick off your Nike sneakers
maybe go pop some instant popcorn in
your microwave oven while waiting for
your conveniently tasty treat maybe make
a couple of calls on your cell phone
yeah the Leafs lost it long I said I'm
sorry then head on upstairs turn on your
television set to watch reruns of
Seinfeld or The Simpsons
and maybe just maybe you can think twice
about how much you hate America oh by
the way what's on your iPod some Celine
Dion Shania Twain maybe actually I got
t-pain and a Pussycat Dolls they know
Ann Marie the idea that America is an
evil empire and constantly in the wrong
is absurd and the fact that Barack Obama
essentially apologized on behalf of
America for the stereotype at the g20
summit is appalling all you folks out
there Canadian or not tell me your
feelings on the USA and how you justify
them and to the Americans out there are
you still proud of your country or
apologetic let me know I think the fact
that Canada continues to exist is proof
of the kindness of America as a nation
you're talking about a country directly
to the north of us with no significant
national defense rich in natural
resources and America is its greatest
ally trust me the United States wanted
to conquer Canada they take it but we
don't because we're not an evil empire
hell-bent on global domination
we are your greatest friends if anything
you guys should be at the frontlines
cheering us on America America he's our
man if he can't do it
well then we surrender eh hey I heard
you would surrender me too
with that goo you one-stop takeoff hoser